this is a production of cornell
university
thank you
thank you it's a pleasure to be here i'm
a little bit more height impaired than
don so i hope everybody can see me from
at least the nose above over this this
monitor it's good to see all these
familiar faces and some new ones i feel
like i'm back in plantations we could
have had this over the nevin vulcan
center and hello geneva
well yes i'm going to be talking a
little bit about biocultural
conservation and i'm going to go through
slowly
getting to that point but then talk
about why it's important that botanic
gardens play a role both in
environmental or biological conservation
as well as
cultural and linguistic
to make sure i find the right
button here but first of all
just a little bit about plantations for
those of you who don't get out much
or for those who are newer than i it
might be just useful to just have a
little brief overview as to who we are
and what we do but our mission if you
just want to boil it down to three words
is probably not much different from any
other public garden in the world
we involved in cultivation
of plants of course and their display
conservation
which includes these days also a very
heavy focus on sustainability and
sustainable practices
and education both formal and informal
because of the way we do these things
with a high level of professionalism
curatorial professionalism
we do consider ourselves as do zoos and
aquaria as living museums we curate our
collections with the highest degree of
professional accuracy we
want to know everything about every
plant that comes in where it came from
how it's doing what his health is
provenance all these kinds of things
and this makes the collections that we
have
much more useful and easier to be
integrated into various scientific and
academic activities
so as such we're integral
to cows
as well as to cornell
more broadly
and there's that more broadly part that
i think may become a little bit more
apparent as we go through this in terms
of other kinds of academic pursuits
and again for those who don't get out
much
it's
plantations is a fairly complex
entity with the botanic gardens around
the welcome center the arboretum across
the way
here as well as 34
natural areas so the total land area is
somewhere around 3 500
what about acres that's the word not
hectares acres
so we are a place that provides
solace it provides places for recreation
informal and formal education as i was
saying before places in which faculty
can bring their students or students can
bring themselves down there and learn
and study and reflect
so our collections
are
based on any number of different themes
some may be more geographic or
ecological and some more horticultural
or taxonomic such as the rhododendron
garden the york robeson york state herb
garden pam shade is the gardener
extraordinaire for this plot it's one of
the best but
reputed to be one of the best
herb gardens in the country and it's
absolutely a fantastic resource
for anybody who's interested in the ways
in which herbs are being used and for
culinary purposes medicinal purposes in
art and literature and the like and
through history
and you know don was sort of alluding to
the weather right now and how am i
adapting but i'm doing fine actually i'm
going to hawaii on wednesday
for a few days it's business don't worry
it's all business but even this time of
year there's plenty to do outside in
terms of horticulture and the winter
interest as a horticulturist or
landscape architects
say of gardens in the winter can be
quite stunning and striking with
gives you more of an opportunity to look
at parts of the plant other than the
leaves and the flowers you can look at
the bark and the color and buds and and
fruits that are still hanging on there
so
the mulestein family winter garden is a
fantastic resource
of course is the 100 acre arboretum all
the natural areas that are around us the
cascadilla and fall creek gorge trails
which are all part of our under our
purview
and then getting into the some of the
sustainability things i haven't talked
about the nevin welcome center but you
know that and don knows more about this
and i do leed certified the bias well
garden helping
manage some of the runoff that comes
from the surrounding area the parking
lot etc and sort of filtering it
biofiltering it before it gets into the
water gets into bb lake
but the faculty and student research is
something that i really want to put a
great deal of emphasis on in the next
few years
not just to our sort of
kinship in in the plant sciences and
horticulture and environmental sciences
but also in the humanities as well and
bring more of a
more artists down there and musicians
and and the like
and really bulk up our education program
so that we appeal
to a broad uh cadre of of students be
they people who are looking for formal
education or those who are just coming
for a more informal
experience
so
for me and for many of us here plants
are inspirational they inspire us in
terms of our research or in terms of the
way we manage our gardens at home
or at work and they've inspired some
people to serve rather perplexing ways
of displaying plants in some places such
as
in versailles
but also they inspire in terms of other
kinds of things we have charismatic mega
fauna such as the panda bear and the
elephants this kind of thing we do have
charismatic megaflora as well for
chrysic so we need to try and get people
involved and excited about the the world
of plants through any kinds of hook
and plants and nature and natural
systems
have inspired the arts in many any
number of ways and this is one of my
favorite recent novels barbara king
solvers prodigal summer which has a
great exposition of how nature works but
also how people interact with nature and
some of the conflicts that are there and
some of the
ways in which those two different types
of systems mesh
and of course it shows up
in any you know in art through the
painting through the ages this is child
hassam's painting of celia faxo's garden
at what's now shoal's marine lab or
apple door island this is celia thaxter
in her garden
so
we're inspired by the art but the art
was inspired by the garden so it all
comes sort of full circle and it can
come full circle in other ways too such
as putting art in the garden such as
chihuly's glassworks
this was a recent i'm not that recent i
guess almost 10 years old uh
installation that fips but dale chihuly
has been traipsing around the world
putting in his glass work in various
places and i think this is great to
appoint
if people come just for the art and
forget to look at anything else around
it i'm not sure that much has been
achieved other than the cash register
ringing and then of course here we have
these sculptures which were part of a
student project back in the 60s so these
are now sculptures in the arboretum but
actually the arboretum came later
probably about 20 years later these were
put in in the early 60s and the
arboretum wasn't officially established
until 1982 so this whole thing sort of
you might say sort of
this forest grew up around these things
and then jack elliot who's over in human
ecology his sculpture well actually it's
not a sculpture it is a maple root
structure that was in front of the
johnson museum for a while last summer
and then we had to transport it down to
us so the ways in which we can engage
people in art that has a botanical or
environmental focus and then get them
hooked and then get more talking about
plants of what they mean to them in
their daily lives in today's society
and one of the unfortunate aspects of
today's society is that many of the
plants and natural resources or systems
that we study are increasingly
threatened by one thing or another one
thing being land use changes and
deforestation
invasive species
climate change
so here here for instance
this has a impact not just
climate change has impact not only on
natural systems but on gardening and how
we garden so here's the
hardiness zone map from 1919 you can see
here we are
firmly in sconston zone five
and here's zone three up here the dark
area now here in the 2006 version we're
almost
out of zone five and look what happened
to zone three it's almost non-existent
in the contaminants united states
so this has a great impact on gardening
as well as our ability
to manage our collections in botanic
gardens and we need to be thinking ahead
as to how we're going to manage our
collections in the light of
these changes
now
one great thing about
being a living museum and keeping great
records on everything that we do is we
can look at phenological data that we
have in our archives and in our
notebooks and look to see how
phenological
events have changed over the course of
time
and we're doing this in chicago and also
in hawaii the royal botanic garden queue
has been doing a lot of work on this and
we have colleagues in boston too richard
primack who's been publishing quite
extensively on this phenomenon as well
but if you look at the flowering dates
of narcissus at q back in the 1950s the
average flowering date was the 9th of
march and now
it's uh late january so it's almost six
week shift in the flowering phenology
just of that one species they did this
for about two dozen different spring
flowering ephemerals and perennials too
and see the very summer shift and it's
anywhere from about
four weeks to eight to ten weeks
so significant and i just got an email
from a friend in in germany last week
saying spring is here
already
so it's amazing so these things these
various environmental issues have a
pose a great threat to the plant life of
the world
and uh chris thomas would publish a
paper about 10 years ago looking at
how many species
in the world are quote unquote committed
to extinction if the current trends
continue and for separated separating
out plants from everything else
he indicated that depending on where you
are in the amazon for instance and
what's already been occurring in certain
places within the amazon anywhere from
50 to 80 percent of the flora there's at
risk of extinction in the next 50 years
or so
in europe it's not quite so bad not
because it's a more resilient system but
because so much has already been wiped
out there's only very little left to be
wiped out
so
norm myers and others since him have
developed what we call biodiversity hot
spots which are just regions of the
world where the flora and fauna is a
particular risk of extinction due to
some of those
factors that i've already mentioned and
as you know and as you can see from here
these tend to be in the tropics and
subtropics and in the mediterranean
region
and you know sometimes you say well out
of
a crisis comes opportunity and this is
an opportunity for us i suppose as a
profession and in horticulture and the
botanic garden community to take a
leadership role and better understanding
and communicating about some of these
issues that are happening and the
effects that they will have on the
natural world
british ecologist william sutherland was
looking at all of this and looking at
endangerment of
birds and mammals using the iucn that's
the international union for the
conservation of nature using their red
listing criteria
and determined that of the almost 10 000
species of bird in the world 12 percent
of them are at risk of extinction in the
next few decades
of the
4 500 or so
species of mammals 24
and he said to himself well that's for
fun just try and use these iucn criteria
for endangerment and see how they might
apply to something else like endangered
languages and it doesn't work very well
but he tried to shoehorn some of these
things into those
criteria and came up with a number of 25
percent of the world's languages are
endangered so bits of our humanity are
as threatened as
other aspects of the
biota of the world however that's
actually quite a low estimate because
they're better ways of estimating the
percentages of languages that are
endangered and unesco uses a fairly
rigorous set of criteria and they've
estimated that about 50
of the 7000 existing languages
are endangered and long-term trends
we're losing about a language about
every two weeks
so about this time last year there was
the last living speaker of a language in
scotland it's called the fisher folk
language that person died so that
language is gone
and there was something in the
press maybe several weeks ago about the
last speaker of a native american
language in the southwest so we're
seeing this happening uh more and more
more more frequently
so people who study endangered languages
have tried to mimic some of these
this hotspot theme
and looking in language extinction hot
spots and again as you might expect
the greatest vulnerability is in the
tropics and subtropics where natural
systems are being rapidly degraded by
deforestation and resource extraction
and native people's indigenous peoples
being displaced of course there are
other other pockets up in northwestern
north america and northeastern
uh russia and china as well where there
are small isolated
indigenous groups
so for looking at the relationship so
what we're seeing here is the explicit
relationship cause and effect
relationship between the loss of
biological diversity around the world
and the loss of
linguistic and cultural diversity they
go hand in hand as as one erodes away is
taking the others down with it
and so this examination of the
relationship between biological
conservation and cultural or linguistic
conservation we call biocultural
conservation and this is an area i think
gardens can be become more deeply
engaged in
as we lose a culture or language we lose
the information that they have
what we call the indigenous ecological
knowledge or traditional ecological
knowledge about the natural world around
them
i went to a lecture last year from by a
woman who's i don't know what you call
her sort of
maybe an ethnomusicologist but she was
looking at aboriginal dances and various
groups throughout northern
australia and she was showing these
videos of these people dancing and then
she was sort of breaking it down parsing
it down showing how each motion had
something to do with the life cycle of a
species of bird when it fledged when the
bread how many offspring it had so this
whole ritual around it so once that
language is gone then all that
knowledge we may call it indigenous or
traditional ecological knowledge but
it's damn good ecological knowledge all
that just disappears so we're all the
poorer for it
as as humanity
so if you're
we're in hawaii or a native hawaiian
and any one of these particular plants
were to disappear then the native
hawaiian culture which is now going
through a renaissance would lose a
significant portion of its identity so
the taro which is a important staple
crop
the koa or ocasio-core which is used for
building canoes and other utilitarian
vessels
though
the metrocenters which is used in
laymaking and other kinds of ornamental
purposes these are some people might
refer to these as sort of cultural
keystone species
as opposed to ecological keystone
species but they're
central to the culture once they're gone
they're gone
and the taro as some of you might know
is a sacred plant throughout many of the
pacific island
cultures they believe that that's their
ancestry and i won't get into the
mythology of that at the moment but in
vanuatu for instance the residents there
say we don't we do not cultivate taro to
live but live to cultivate taro because
it's keeping alive their ancestral
heritage
and if you follow the news about gmo and
all that kind of thing there's been
quite a bit of hue and cry about this
particularly in the pacific
islands i mean it worked okay with the
papaya in fact there was a cornell
breeder who came up with a ring spot
resistant papaya and that's now being
widely grown in hawaii but that's one of
the exceptions
they're also diseases of taro that have
been going
you know through the pacific from time
to time and wiped out much of the taro
cultivation in samoa and so they
resorted reluctantly to using gmo taro
well the hawaiian said no way though i
knew 11 said no way because you don't do
gmo on your ancestor i mean it's just
heretical so there's been a lot of
place
instances in which sort of quote-unquote
western science or western approach
which is the things that conflicted or
intersected with some of the other
traditional ones but it's an opportunity
for learning
more about how other cultures see the
world around them and and appreciate
that more
more heavily
so with respect to sea level rise again
in the pacific the republic of kiribati
which is about uh 32
flat coral atolls no more than two
meters high
and for this is a trivia thing
so somebody says what's what's the only
country in the world which spans which
what
is present in all four hemispheres so
kiribati because the international date
line comes right down here and the
equator goes right through here so it's
in all four hemispheres
anyway
so sea level rise just a few centimeters
of sea level rise is going to
cause huge issues
as it is now here's the capital
town it's underwater here people who've
never seen water above their knees on
these atolls is now already up to their
ankles or above
and so now what they're doing is trying
to find a home they're going to be one
of the first in full entire nations that
is sort of an environmental refugee
status
fiji at the time i put this together
negotiating
to buy another negotiating can we just
please live there
uh 5 000 acres in fiji fiji is saying no
at the moment another
seeing of either australia or new
zealand will take some of them these
people's about a hundred thousand people
now if you go a little further afield up
to the northwest
north america this is alaska
in the northwest territories they're
about two dozen different languages and
cultures here of
first nations people or whatever the
appropriate term is these days
any one of which is dwindling
so if you look at this area up here with
a nuclear are in the far northern part
as a sea level as the sea
water temperature rises they're finding
the whales and other mammals and animals
that they hunt are moving further north
and so they're out there hunting in
these sort of rudimentary canoes and
they can't get out as far or they may be
able to get out as far but there's no
way they're going to get back in time
and so their ability to hunt for the
resources that they need is being
increasingly diminished
there's a nice uh write-up about this in
a book recently
cavallina that's the name of the town in
which they they live
so these environmental changes are
changing the natural world is having a
direct consequence on the cultural world
and here is part of their landscape
that's just
literally melting and going away and
going into the ocean
so
people who study this botanists and
ethnobotanists
anthropologists linguists have been
trying to develop a map
and how can we display or portray this
biocultural diversity we showed
languages
in terms of hot spots
biological hot spots but what about this
biocultural thing combining the two it's
very difficult because they're two very
different types of data and information
so combining the two into a single index
is almost it's not impossible but it's
very difficult and so this was a very
crude attempt
by david law and john harmon
and entire countries are coded a single
color even here an entire continent
certain colors the deeper the color the
more
endangered are both the biological
elements and the cultural elements
within that region
and it doesn't show therefore because of
the lack of fine grain some of these
areas up here or up here in the
northwest
or even across northern australia where
there are huge numbers of very small
indigenous groups remaining
this is another attempt that unesco did
with along with the world wildlife fund
that's just as unsatisfying the colors
here are just depicting the bio regions
of the world and you can't see at this
scale but they're just little dots
everywhere just shows where an
endangered culture or endangered
languages so they just superimpose one
thing over another
so
it is still a work in progress
so
i show this this is a
rare plant in hawaii it's an extinct in
the wild this is cyania truncata the
only place in the world you can see this
is in a test tube at the lion arboretum
what we can do is we can clone it every
individual will be genetically identical
but at least we can clone it and if
there's a habitat suitable we can put it
back out into nature once we grow these
things up in the greenhouse but you
can't put a culture in a test tube
you can do that with plants but once the
culture is gone it's gone
and
no lesser person of francois jacob than
nobel laureate in medicine in 1965 said
that in humans
natural diversity is further
strengthened by cultural diversity and
i'm hoping that we can as we develop our
programs
more at the cornell plantations and with
partnership from people at cornell other
departments that we can
dive into this
issue more deeply
there are a number of international
entities treaties and conventions and
such that will
draw these two issues together uh the
convention on biological diversity which
every nation in the world has ratified
except the us
uh george herbert walker bush signed it
but congress didn't ratify it so we're
we try to live up to its tenets towards
articles um but there's no
mandate that we do so but i think it
seems to be the right thing to do and
most people who work in
gardens and museums respect
the convention on biological diversity
but in a number of places within this
convention including this article 8j
they do refer to maintaining
indigenous and local communities for the
conservation and sustainable use of
biological diversity so they're making
an attempt here again to bring bring
these two together we can't do the one
without the other
something that's a little bit more close
to home for those in the botanic garden
world
is the global strategy for plant
conservation
which came out of the convention on
biological diversity and a number of us
from gardens around the world worked
quite a bit on developing this over the
last 10 years or so and it has targets
we had targets from
2000 2010 and now we have new targets
from 2010 to 2020.
such as
inventorying and having
electronical databases that document
every living plant in the world and all
these kinds of things because how are we
going to preserve what we have unless we
know exactly what we have and know the
full extent of it one of these targets
again like the conventional biological
diversity again refers to this
intersection between biological and
cultural conservation halting the
decline of plant resources and
associated indigenous and local
knowledge innovations and practices and
that's just a snippet out of that target
so you can get the gist of it
and there are i think there are 18 or 20
of these targets some of them have to do
as i said with digitizing
the floor of the world and these kinds
of things where you can say yes we've
done this much we've done we've done 75
of it or 85 or whatever the case may be
developing new educational programs or
communication strategies around all of
this this is a much harder one to get a
grip on and it's the one that tends to
be ignored just because it's a little
bit more difficult
to address
but gardens are addressing this
nonetheless those of you who've been to
new york much have been to queen's
botanic garden know that it's probably
in one of the most ethnically diverse
places in the us
and they've made an explicit attempt
to draw in the various ethnic groups
that are within
their
their area
and give them a place where they can
express themselves culturally
particularly as it relates to foods and
plants and that within their daily lives
and so they have a number of events a
number of festivals that aren't catered
just for you know for filipinos to
filipinos but filipinos to everybody
else so everybody can get a taste
figuratively and literally of what that
culture represents and how plants are
central
centrally important to the maintenance
of their
culture i've been working on and off
with rohingyas
in jordan who is establishing
a network of
new botanic gardens throughout jordan
there'll be a main central garden in
amman and then other satellite gardens
throughout the country and those
satellite ones are intended to do things
two things one is to showcase
the biota
and the biological diversity of that
particular region and the other is to
show the
the cultural significance of the peoples
in that region because they vary from
place to place
so these are even though she's not
calling it that these are biocultural
gardens
and she's financing these personally
because the government is not doing it
even though she's part of the royal
family
so she's doing it herself
and another place that's
doing this
and
i consulted with them briefly a couple
of years ago is in south korea where
they're building a new city southwest of
seoul
the city is going to be huge it's going
to be about three times the size of
paris or some such thing and
it's enormous and this is a scale model
that they have in the visitor center
showcasing this new big
r d and
city and have all these fancy apartments
and all these kinds of things the only
thing they've done so far is build the
sea wall which is the world's longest
sea wall 35 kilometers long with a four
lane highway on the top and two two lane
highways on either side that's really
grotesque in some ways
so they're doing this in this estuary
and the only saving grace and the
lighting here doesn't allow to show up
very clearly is right in here
this is what they wanted me to come
there for is they're building a 100
hectare biocultural garden
so it's going to be a garden that
showcases the biological heritage and
cultural heritage of that part of the
korean peninsula and the
chinese mainland that's just across the
sea from there
which i thought was quite an interesting
i'm not particularly
uh a fan of the rest of what they're
proposing to do here particularly big
golf courses and that kind of thing but
this is just a plan and these things
change and is you know given the current
economic state of the world it's
probably just as likely that this will
never happen
but there are people who are thinking
about this at least in terms of how can
we bring
people and the cultural heritage of the
world more close to the issues that
we're facing in with respect to
conserving the natural world
so as dawn alluded to when i was at
university of hawaii i established a
center for biocultural
studies there and what we did was draw
in people from anthropology linguistics
of the law school as they had law
faculty who are looking at climate
change and its impacts on indigenous
peoples and resource extraction
uh indigenous intellectual property
rights and all these kinds of things
so it ran the gamut i mean there wasn't
probably there was very few departments
at the university didn't in some way
have some connection to this particular
issue
and we developed partnerships as part of
that and mou's with the university of
auckland and new zealand
what we were doing in hawaii relates to
what going on there with the maori
population unesco is interested in this
too
at the university of south pacific in
fiji the smithsonian through their
recovering voices program
the east-west center which is a
non-profit big think tank in honolulu
looking at ways in which western and
eastern cultures can intersect and
support one another
so there's a lot of interest
in this it's just a
matter of articulating what the issues
are and making connections with people
in other disciplines
we held a
which is now every other year an
international conference on endangered
languages
at the university of hawaii and we had
people come there from all over the
world including people from google they
sent six people to this we had no idea
they were coming they just came in they
said announced themselves and after the
conference they said we want to help you
build
a website just for endangered languages
so they did they built it for us and now
all we have to do all is find the
linguists ethnobotanists
ethnomusicologists and others who are
documenting endangered languages and
cultures and put their information on
this public publicly accessible site
it's like a well-managed or well-edited
wiki really is what it is so there are
people now the university of hawaii who
manage manage this and this new
information comes and they vetted and
make sure it's all up to snuff
and now bringing all this back closer to
home you say what the hell does this
have to do with it in cornell but
and this is the white well i shouldn't
have said this is white pine tree who
knows what this tree is come on
robert
so this is an iconic tree in the
northern you know sort of mixed
hardwoods forests everywhere from
minnesota to the to the northeast
and it holds a special place
in
native american culture the hudan rasani
i said that right confederacy
it's the original moocs m-o-o-c-s
mohawk hanaida anadaga
cayuga and seneca that's how i remember
just remember moocs for those of you in
higher education so that's right you
know what that is
so
they
so so to them the white pine is
is a very
key element of their cultural history
and we had a display on this at the
never welcome center when i first came
and i still don't know
it was just by happenstance that i'm
interested in this and happened to be
there or somebody said let's get this
guy done
anyway so they have there's all the
symbolism so they have how many needles
in the fascicle per fascicle of a white
pine
five okay so the [ __ ]
the they represent each of those native
american uh confederate nations that are
part of this confederacy
and this on symbolism there's a eagle on
the top of the tree and all this kind of
thing
but if the tree falls over if it's
tipped over in a windstorm or whatever
the root ball comes up you've got this
big depression in the ground and that's
where they would bury their weapons and
then cover them up then the rainwater
the stream or whatever would carry away
that violence
that'd be the end of war supposedly
anyway so they call it here the tree of
the great long leaves but it's also
referred to in their culture as the tree
of peace
so if the white pine were to disappear
not that it will
but it has been threat has been
threatened over centuries by
logging over logging and
one disease or another you know that's
possible that something like this could
disappear from a culture and there there
goes another piece of that culture's
integrity
so some other things we're doing and
done
reykjav can speak to these much more
uh
expertly than can i but
we can also
refer to and acknowledge and respect
other cultures just through horticulture
as well and so
we plan on continuing to promote this
east asian garden that don was involved
in developing
as a way to get people more engaged in
asian cultures and how plants have been
used
in those cultures for ornamental
aesthetic and other purposes so there'll
be some focus
unless things change dramatically on
korean
some aspects of korean japanese and
korean culture and how they use plants
in various
in various ways
and this is not just a and if you think
about
19 percent i read of
cornell
undergraduates self-identify as asian so
that's either american or from asia
coming here from asia for school that's
a significant population here and
there's very little here that's for them
and
we don't have to do something just for
them but it's also an opportunity for us
to learn more about them so it goes both
ways
then the peony and perennial garden
which may be in that great lawn area or
a portion of it we depending on how the
fundraising goes and all this kind of
thing things always change and scales
change but peonies are another plant
that are very important some aspects of
asian horticulture and gardens so there
ways in which we can draw different
cultures in here and then from there we
can explore out in any number of
different avenues
so if you're wondering what the hell did
was that all about here's the summary
slide we're living museums so we have to
maintain our horticulture and
educational excellence that goes without
saying
so some people say well
you're not going to be a botanic
gardener anymore yes we are going to be
a better one
and a more impactful one and we have to
remain indispensable to to cornell to
the faculty of the students add to the
community and forge relationships and
partnerships with people in other
disciplines in the humanities in
particular
and social sciences
and
and do more in terms of informing people
about this intimate link and this sort
of co-ed evolutionary link between
uh nature and cultures
and i usually like to close things by
this
uh phrase from shakespeare
that he put in the words of ulysses and
i think otherwise i just can't get
through tourists and cressida
but anyway he said one touch of nature
makes the whole world kin and i think if
we use this as our mantra moving forward
and think about some this nature and
culture thing will have left the world a
better place
so thank you very much for your
attention
how many of your graduate students
are undergraduate
so do you take courses in some of these
other areas what
i have so i have graduate students come
to me from time to time well give me
your best career advice i said don't
focus you know
you get so
deeply embedded in this that statistics
course or that biochemical system and
things that relate to
getting together in that particular
field but
it's really useful
they don't make of course headphones
anymore they're a hard copy i don't
think back in the day you could just go
like this and uh stick your fingers
somewhere they're going to take that
course
as the musicology of forever whatever
the case may be
so i think it could make your
yes
you alluded to you know
uh maybe having a more active role in
the humanities and social sciences are
there particular departments
within the cornell that
you're kind of seeking to build those
well we're doing some of that through
the lecture series that happened with
paul and the sonia were being
have a
pretty good relationship now with the
english department but i want to expand
on that
theater
filmmaking
there's a fellow toby macau
just a revival by toby mccloud's the
non-profit
called sacred lands project and he's
been going around the world videotaping
these different cultures
mainly disappearing cultures and talking
they need to give them about their
relationship to the landscape
around them so i'm interested in working
with people like that as well we can't
work with them directly here we can
bring some of these people in too
so it's funny he doesn't know this but
um thinking about ways in which we can
get some of this information out through
these lecture series and so what if we
had this woman who's indian who did a
bit of this
multimedia kind of thing called
himalayan snow where she's looking at uh
climate change in the himalayas
the snow melting the glaciers melting
and the impact that's having on those
cultures that live in around the
mountains
there and then what impact that cultural
loss is having on her mother in new york
because now her culture there is
disappearance so she's dreaming this
loss herself so you can connect those
dots generation generationally and
connect them geographically spatially
and temporarily
and so what she does is she has this
video thing that's playing while she's
talking over and then there's this epic
music from displaying physical movement
as well and it's extremely powerful
so i don't want it to be pedantic
necessarily or lecturing
as we get more into these things at
least
we need to not only approach the
humanities but to some extent we also
need to take that humanities approach in
some ways to overcome our community
yes yeah um hi i was really um pleased
to see when you were talking about
biocultural um diversity that then you
brought the issue back to
um you know kind of where we are today
with the um
and iroquois i think one of the issues
that i mean it sounds easy to talk about
preserving plants and everybody wants to
protect the white pine or the black ash
or
those types of things and and thinking
about um you know forming partnerships
with with native peoples in in the
region but the place where it gets hard
is in terms of political sovereignty and
this last year 2014
was the 400th year of the two-world
wampum which represents the the
political agreement between iroquois
nishoni peoples and
non-native peoples it started with the
dutch but then it also kind of frames
the relationship between the
haudenosaunee and u.s people today and
where that comes the kind of rubber
meets the road in difficulty is that
much of new york state is under land
claim conflict meaning that these people
for whom we would like to save the white
pine um have serious and legitimate
claims to property in new york state
based on political sovereignty and so to
not recognize that um is to kind of
frame the question um in
not a trivial way but in a way that
doesn't really recognize
um that native indigenous peoples in new
york state
in northern north america are indigenous
political entities with the desires to
have their own land their own government
and all the rest and so biocultural
conservation when we form partnerships
like that to be effective the very first
thing has to recognize the political
sovereignty of those groups so i salute
you for bringing up the biocultural
diversity and say let's not forget that
there is political and all sorts of
issues that go along with this right
here in our own backyard and talk to
people in kyogre county about how
friendly they are with the human nation
and you'll probably get slapped in the
face right because they don't like the
kids and they could care less about the
white pie
well okay
that's true when i was setting up this
i agree with all of that yeah
we did get because they were native
americans fault with a lot of native
american i mean native points you know
whines on the faculty there who are all
engaged to this um
in the nationwide studies program as
well as in the law school another so yes
we did bring in all that whole political
thing
and
there's a it's a pretty dynamic system
there too in hawaii and in aotearoa in
new zealand
and
but through these different partnerships
developed respect and from there you can
work together and try to resolve some of
these things so it's working out quite
well in hawaii
right now and i outfit always working
out
fairly well and i have no doubt the
situation here will be resolved in some
way that
not everybody is unhappy
christopher it seems that in considering
this rapid loss of indigenous languages
that it's either being caused by
geographic changes such as these people
living on the atolls no longer being
able to live there because of rising
ocean levels or because
members of the groups speak those
languages are migrating to cities and no
longer identifying with their culture or
the people are just dying out so
given those factors
what
realistically practically can be done to
preserve things
like well that's where we work with
anthropologists and logistics
interests more than anybody else they
don't want to
help us with that
and generally what happens is that go to
these places where this is occurring
and you interview with people and some
of them say
we don't want your health
we doubt we die our community better off
if we did assimilate into a lot of
different cultures
so
some of these languages are going to die
out because that's what they want
for one reason or another
there are many in which they do want
their culture to be unhappy with
devoting the fact
the least we can do is
archive for posterity and understand it
and have it interpreted so we know what
all these words and magic
and stories and songs and dances mean
and
getting information from that
beyond that
what is happening in some places is
instituting
language training programs many of the
older people talk about really how
medicinal medicinals for some of these
cultures they have the past they have it
written out in their language but these
paths are really used for
whatever so they can use those as
teaching tools for the next generation
so
i'm not an expert in that there are any
number of different ways in which some
of that can be reversed
but the big thing in order for a
language to remain viable is that it has
number one it has to be passed down from
one generation to the next
and so when you're looking to see if
your language is in danger that's the
first thing you look at is the language
being transmitted it doesn't mean
transmitted then you have to look at
what
can we do
first
of course
and what i've noticed from the students
and the public is that the incredible
interest
in plants
and medicine and health
and it's rare that you go to gardens
anywhere
but they're very really very conscious
of this
i mean the public
is constantly consuming all kinds of
botanical stuff
i wish they're clueless
what they're thinking
they are i mean it's a multi-billion
industry so i think my question is
how can gardens
get into a topic which deals with
medicine
deals with
health which everybody is interested in
and you can touch especially in the
ancient medicine of the american indians
from north america south america i mean
it's an incredible wealth
and i'm just
going to answer that question
well
we in the herb garden at the plantations
we have
17 themed beds
we have two beds that are devoted to
medicinal plants
many of which are originate in western
and europe
european culture and um a few from china
and a few from
india
and we also have
one of the theme
herbs of the native of american
indians it's very small and
they are located all around us in the
trees the trees are medicine
the shrubs are medicine we're you know
they they have medicinal properties so
they're featured all around us not just
within this complex in this very small
bed and the wildflower garden at the
plantations has
the woodland
native plants some of which are
medicinal and some are edible
so it's through interpretive programs i
think that we learn
a lot more
because we can only feature a small a
very small percentage within the context
of the herb garden
so then
bring in guest speakers native guest
speakers
have jane
give us some programs and
maybe network help us network
with the indigenous population
there's a
state historic
park called phenondagon which is in
victor new york outside of victor new
york about an hour and a half north of
here and they um
our state park
on the site of an old seneca historic
village where they had 150 longhouses
and it's a it's a magnificent site a
great resource for us
but also
researchers and students
and such
so that they can
use the plan materials they can extract
the chemicals they can test them to see
if they do have uh academically that
kind of thing yes so we can be a
resource for that
so that's part of our mission is to be a
resource for you
to be able to do that work and your
students will do that for the betterment
of their kind
so whatever we can do
to assist in that that's what we're
there for i have 20 undergraduates doing
that that's too many working with oh no
actually we need to cut things off i
want to again thank dr dunn for that
fascinating lecture
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu